pennsylvania's democratic u.s senate
candidate is returning to the campaign
trail for the first time since he
suffered a stroke back in may that's
lieutenant governor john fetterman he
plans to appear in erie pennsylvania
later today he talked to our pittsburgh
station that's kdka tv about his
recovery
i really want people to understand that
i have zero no physical limits really
the only issues uh lingering from uh the
stroke is just having some
auditorial processing every now and then
and i'll miss a word looks and sounds
pretty good this morning we have an in
don't you think yeah yeah
considering you suffered a stroke in may
this morning we've got an inside look at
the stresses working in a fiercely
partisan and very divided washington the
pressure the doctors say can be very
harmful to your health two senate
democrats chris van hollen and ben ray
lujan both suffered strokes earlier this
year and they've been recovering and
re-evaluating their very busy schedules
they told scott mcfarlane what they've
learned and offered a warning to others
who may be at risk
i couldn't get a few words in before my
doctor said you need to get to the
emergency room they said it was a good
thing i came in because we can see some
bleeding
in in the brain new mexico's ben ray
lujan and maryland's chris van hollen
each suffered a stroke this year both
democratic senators say they survived
because they sought help after the first
warning signs for stroke those include
lack of balance dizziness vision
problems and slurred speech doctors say
many ignore those symptoms but when
lujan was rushed to the er doctors took
immediate action this last scan that you
got your brain is still swelling we need
to go in there and help you out he
underwent intensive invasive brain
surgery followed by weeks off the job in
rehab which continued through the spring
as he returned to work
just two months after lujan's return to
a standing ovation at the capitol
senator van hollen had just started a
campaign speech at first he felt fine
but as you can see he leans on the
podium to steady himself i felt
lightheaded i had a pain in my neck and
my ears were popping a little bit like
you're on an airplane doctors found a
tear and a vein in the back of his head
no surgery but van hollen needed a week
of hospitalization followed by rest at
home
like so many people recovering from
illness or injury they felt an urgency
to return to work and with 50
republicans and 50 democrats in the
senate just one absence can stall
anything there's a question of getting
the votes on some big pieces of
legislation but i think the lesson for
all of us
is
you got to look out for your health dr
celine gander says demanding situations
can take a toll we do certainly see a
link between stress and high blood
pressure whether you're getting enough
sleep by senate standards lujan and van
hollen are young lujan just turned 50
van hollen 63. in the senate anxiety can
be easy to find while rest is not we do
have very stressful jobs we're running
in a million different
directions the senators say like so many
of us who have busy jobs and busy lives
they need to set aside time to do less
you need to find a way to make time
whether it's a little extra time in the
morning in the afternoon or just
catching your breath
make time to keep yourself healthier it
is all too common for us to see patients
in the hospital who have just delayed
deferred their care even when there have
been warning signs these two senators
survived
and now have their own warning for
others when you're feeling these strange
symptoms
don't just brush them off which we so
often do just keep an eye on folks and
if you see a sign as well instead of
just feeling a sign work with that
person to get them checked and get them
in right away too
senator lujan says as the summer
progresses he feels better and stronger
than he did before the stroke but as
recent votes have shown here at the
capitol as the summer progresses his
party still doesn't have a vote to spare
nate
scott thank you
yes
very good advice i'm curious because you
know i'm new to the morning news space
it's stressful
well how do you balance workloads that's
a that's a very good question
i so many times power through and you
when you listen to scott's report
terrifying it is terrifying you really
do need to pay attention yeah you need
to pay attention to your body yeah you
got to make time to do less i know it's
an interesting phrase yeah i'm going to
try to incorporate that one that's good
right there it sounds like it's so far
none of us are doing that i'm not making
time to do that make time to make news
yeah or at least report it that's for
sure